Haa
[music]
Oh, hello, back generation
.
It's just that we can't stop talking
like that.The students will have to talk about it at the prosecutor's office.The
funds you've provided so far will be used correctly
.
The ruling party's young number is safe, is
n't it?  Please wh
[music]
New factory
Negotiations with the expansion of relations will be completed and the media and information will be disclosed 3 hours later
Everything is as planned
End
me It's
time
[music]
I'm not your enemy
can you do as
cant see
thank you masu
wh
[music]
voodoo
dee
[music]
wh
t 10
tee
listen
3 types
ran
me
meditate  It's time like this to straighten up your spine and laugh
Finally, you can buy it at school I've been born with a solid
mind.
Yes Yes
tan
Kuon
[music]
me beniko Tendayo ah ah ah yeah yeah yeah Pitter scene
[music] I
have it dismantled
Read and sing
I got a ticket for Munch and the front row of the arena  Well, what kind of
trick was it? There's also a webcast, but
anyway, it's a ball
anyway Percy handsome guy appeared in the preliminaries with a shabby mood
.  A little gritty or this is
outdone Thank you very much ---
Ah, you can leave it
there Well then I'll go up soon
So we can't compete in Godogu High School.
I'd like you to
show me the way, but that's right, I'm in the same department.
Nigigahon
border
y Isn't it dangerous?
There's no surgery, Tower
Shay This is a live broadcast from the village The
sky is clear and the scenery is the same as usual No, I'll introduce the town to Mina, who's watching
]
Who is this
me
[music]
Yoga Manabu Koga You're interested in the discussion
?  The thief is chairman Jalousie 2-chan
[music] There
was
[music]
ah ah
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
[music]
Ah
Pop haters,
this town ek, the atmosphere is also set up You should ride the stop
[music]
Aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaan too
dee
[music]
rank
wh Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
I've kept you waiting for a very long time,
tan.
Those who believe in the pride of the world will make their own fists
Any wish will come true That is the power of God From
now on, the god of high school
Bell tower will hold the
front  I
'll pay for it later
I can't see it in my eyes It's probably the snatcher's fault
if I claim it over there It's a failed opening ceremony
But really thank you just
now  Hey
[music]
Dear 10 Mirax
players, it's time, please stand by
This venue
has gathered all kinds of martial arts fighters scouted by the tournament management.
It's a martial arts tournament Time
There are no restrictions on the use of weapons You
can win if you make your opponent a perfect human
[ __ ]  I'm deciding
Everyone here at the time of the players
ten
[music]
[applause]
ah ah ah umm
say don't have
[music]
Players all vitals are managed with this bracelet
Granular
Check the state of the second place in real time along
with the
nanomachine injection received at the time of the
event.  Any wish will be granted and the
right will be given.It's about time for an
explanation.You
can start fighting right
away.
Yes,
it's
a
battle royale, look at the battle royale, come
on.  The participants who came back l gradually
started to disappear
rar
[music] There
is
no shhh iphone I have to win to survive
]
[music]
I guess there's a place where there's a referee who was hurt by a scouted participant [music] No, they're all knocked down
, revenge on
the blondes.  to win
Ah, this is funny
because it's only the ones that haven't shown their true colors yet tan
[music]
Now
let's celebrate The formalities are finally over, isn't it?
This girl is a candidate for the championship
Ban Manseok is a player who is currently on maternity leave and has a hp consumption rate of 20%.
But it was better to do it strong me
yeah yeah yeah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ahhh
4 ping pong
tee
I'm dating a different character
ran
[music]
I can't play cute things  I've opened the Frankie-lifted briefs, and the
contents are Mr. Doi.
I'm out alone
rar
[music]
nn voodoo [music] [music] voodoo [music] goo nan 2 ran nan Pokezone
me
[music]
when
one
[music]
voodoo
ah ah ah